The Joe Rogan Experience there's so much
of you know when people think about
Rolling Stone a lot of people think
about the early days you think about
Hunter you know they think about when
you uh you guys covered his run for
Sheriff I mean that was a that was a
giant moment in culture too that this
[ __ ] madman was running for Sheriff
and the Panic the moral Panic that
people had about oh my God what if this
guy actually becomes a sheriff and takes
up all the streets and locks up all the
drug dealers who are actually selling
drugs
he's gonna lock up bad drug deals right
all the drug dealers that were sellers
they were selling bad drugs that he was
going to put up stocks yeah kind of on a
main square and you had to be in a stock
like you know old Williamstown
Massachusetts or something he wanted
that they saw the streets and I'll just
rip up all the outside to make anything
grass which was good yeah
rename the city from Aspen to Fat City
on the theory Hunter came over that
would be more difficult for land
developers to sell something kind of
called Fat City Estates than the Aspen
of States you know and then
you couldn't the police had to be
unarmed and then there'll be a giant
parking lot out of town that you could
park at and nobody other than residence
residents could not Hunter non-residents
couldn't hunt their fish but he came
close to winning and this was in a very
wealthy Resort town that was starting to
have a hippie population
when we published his his piece about
that and it was the first thing he did
for Rolling Stone it was called freak
power in the Rockies
or the Battle of Aspen so
it got such serious attention another
press and film Crews from New York and
always the hippies are going to try and
take over the ski Town well let's see
what happens you know so much press came
in it just raised the stakes it became
quite a serious Showdown campaign at
this wealthy Resort
which they came very close to winning
but
two things about her just off the bat
Hunter became just the DNA of Rolling
Stone I mean
his spirit
is thinking
his sense of adventure his sense of fun
his commitment to a better America
we're
at the Spirit heart of what we did and
these were the same things that I felt
and so we we we just felt we became very
fast friends I mean we just locked in
almost immediately that we saw something
special between us that we
did together he could write and I could
edit and you know like and we were very
Partners in a very real sense of the
world there was never after we first met
was never a question of whether or not
we would work not work with it it was
always from now on we were together and
he was always overseeing
the what we were doing the magazine game
with ideas stories and writers and he
felt very committed to making the
magazine a success in additional he
Hunter is a uh and I love Hunter and to
this day miss him terribly terribly and
I wrote my book I said well wherever you
know Hunter ends up I want to go there
too you know who knows where that'll be
but you know I mean
you know he just meant that much yeah
the um the documentary The Gonzo
documentary there was the the first time
I ever really got to see you talk about
him and you know
you're kind of the glue that holds a
documentary together because you're sort
of the rational Observer that was there
during all the wildest and most mad
times
he had I mean everybody loved to be with
Hunter I mean you couldn't you couldn't
get enough of being with Hunter you know
and including me after having hunts for
so much when you're with Hunter when you
were with Hunter you were like felt
you're gonna have more fun and become
close to the edge out of craziness and
danger than you ever working in your
life you know just getting in the car
with Hunter you know you'd he he would
always have to do something that scare
this piss out of you uh you know u-turns
in the middle of a snowbound highway and
one night we were driving from Cambridge
to
uh
New Hampshire to visit Norman mailer for
some strange reason we had spent the
night in Cambridge and we had taken some
acid and we got on the road head full of
acid driving up in the middle of the
night to me and it's all mountain roads
and so we go along and then all of a
sudden like Hunter would turn the
headlights off
and I mean I you have mixed feelings at
this point I've one I've by this time
developed just since I'm safe with
Hunter no no matter how crazy is he
knows what he's doing all the time which
he did
um so on the other hand he liked the
idea of freaking people out so I was go
ah oh 100 stop it stop it you know like
and it would just make him happier to
know that I was freaking out you know it
was partly just to keep him going but
then I realized what he was doing is he
was
looking ahead two bends and memorizing
the curves ahead so they could turn off
the lights which is risky in itself but
we we got to nailers we were visiting
some a colleague of Mars who was staying
in Mars house we had the night before
and taking us and made a tape on an old
cassette tape of scream like an exorcism
you know and screaming in this house
you know the Gold's gone nuts so we get
up there at 7 A.M in the morning and set
the tape deck in the kitchen of the
house punch it so it starts with the
screaming at the top of him and run out
the door and they'll come back
well he'd love to do that so we we steal
restaurant signs and I mean there's all
sorts of Madness and crazy and it was
fun you know and it was innocent it was
like being a kid you know it got in Part
Hunter was a big kid but also
you know I he
was just a wonderful guy and of course
the funniest writer ever I enjoyed his
copy coming I just laughed my head off
of some of the things he'd say I mean
unbelievably funny I think the first
thing I read was the the Vegas story
that was one of the first pieces I ever
read of him and I remember thinking like
whoo [ __ ] writes like this like it's it
was I don't remember how old I was when
I read it but you know it was before I
think it was before or around the time
Johnny Depp played him in the movie
no much before no I mean when I read it
yeah because I think the movie
introduced it to him
the movie introduced to Hunter yeah wow
I mean you even believe such a person
took place but that was a faithful
portrayal yeah of an individual and
lucky me
uh he got to be my closest friend for
many years and we worked together so
closely and all the time for many years
and um
he was Johnny got him really well and
Johnny loved him he wrote Vegas in
I think was 1970 I think
was about the time 70 or 71 no 70
because 7172 was campaign Trail he wrote
that it was when he was writing he
started writing it in my basement in San
Francisco where he was living staying
with us and um he just he was on
assignment to do something else some
serious thing about the Chicano Uprising
in
East Los Angeles but
in the middle of that so I mean he had
to go to Vegas
to cover a motorcycle race for sports
illustrate and they wanted like a 200
word caption but he never turned that in
instead
started running this piece about going
to Vegas saying we begins we were
somewhere on the edge of Barstow and the
drugs took hold and then the image of
this red Cadillac that trunk full of
animals uppers downers guns you know
just Madness
um
but uh that
peace was so strong
in two parts it was a novel you know a
short novel
a clear it became as regarded as a
classic of American literature day up
with kind of like Huck Finn or catcher
in Orion stuff like that uh you know
interesting another story about the kind
of adolescent spirit and all of us of
men who just can't give up being little
boys and cherish that wonderful
freedom and
fun sense of fun we all that none of us
ever like to give up really you know
there's still lingers with that I look
in your eyes I can see it you know the
mess but
uh I've lost my point it's it it ignited
this appetite for chaos in people that
were dissatisfied
with the narrative that they had been
told about the life that you were
supposed to live and the way you're
supposed to go about things and
you know and then the 70s was just such
a pivotal moment too because they had
illegalized they had made uh all
psychedelic drugs illegal and there was
this water that was being thrown on this
movement and so quickly sort of
evaporated so quickly that the shift
between the 50s and the 60s was kind of
paralleled between the shift of the 70s
into the 80s
at the end yeah things change I mean
let's come
that's a complicated let me just you you
think what you said about it liberated
the chaos and yeah the ignited and
appetite for chaos exactly that it was
an accepted that it didn't have the
terror that you could live Loosely or
openly or even have to obey all this
rules that that's what that's what Dylan
was about too you know about the
complexity of life and all things going
on in your head and you know the the two
great Dylan albums bring it all back
home and I was 61 about chaos
but
at the yeah at the end of the 70s I mean
the 80s was the era of Reagan I mean
once you have Reagan leading the country
things change you know the mood is
different the values of society seem
different in the 70s we had either a
full-scale rebellion going on against
Nixon you know which was an exciting
time to be alive and seeing the
Watergate hearings and gessels with a
triumphalon stuff and then Carter as the
end of the 70s you know the first real
rock and roll president uh and who
Hunter
had a great love of and who uh
Carter loved him
you know and Carla Dylan and
was of that spirit it's a great there's
a great moment in the documentary where
um
it talks about Hunter being at Carter's
speech and going back to get his tape
recorder and and recognizing that this
is uh this is a very unusual moment and
this guy's different
he was going up the Carters talking
about
quality of Justice yeah you know and
talking about his spiritual ideas that
he got from Reinhold neighbor if I
pronounced that correctly and
according Dillon and
very unusual for politicians yeah and it
was an accident like it looked like
Teddy Kennedy was going to run for
president than to be the nominee so we
were Hunter was following Teddy around
and Teddy had to go to Georgia to be a
guest of honor the law at the law school
there for law day and Carter spoke and
gave this remarkable thing you don't
hear people politicians talk like that
then anyway he didn't and
but I was knocked out and we kind of got
aboard the
uh Carter campaign
wrote about Hunter almost you know kind
of
we became a part of it in a way uh and
between Connor's coverage of the
McGovern campaign
and the car came in it particularly the
government put Rolling Stone on the map
in a way although we'd undone big
stories and broken things before the
idea that we were the rock and roll
magazine was covering National politics
and furthermore the guy doing it was
best known for covering motorcycle gangs
you know plus sweating all the time
because he's
and it brought real attention to us
because Hunter wrote the best coverage
of the campaign the best stuff about the
Kennedy is the best about the political
strategy and also in Rolling Stones part
of the the annual big National story
competing with the New York Times
everybody else head on and he beat them
all we were better than the rest of them
yeah well that was that was where it
really sort of
captured the way young people are
actually feeling
versus the way it was being described
want some more of that I think I'd go
quick with the water okay
I mean that was you know what what your
magazine had covered and what he had
covered with fear and loathing on the
campaign Trail it was the way young
people were feeling about it versus the
way it was being represented on
television and in newspapers and it was
people finally had a real voice that
spoke to them and it really resonated
with people yeah because to see it
through Hunter's eyes also it was the
first time the 18 year olds were allowed
to vote was in 1972 And so that made it
extra interesting to young people and
also there was a war in Vietnam that's a
big background I mean that was yeah yeah
that makes everything
stand out of high relief
but also Hunter was extremely fun they
were pieces you didn't have to know
anything about politics to read those
pieces they were so funny I mean these
things is coming up with like Senator
Muskie was shooting a game on the
campaign I mean and literally people
would come up to me and say is it true
about The Ether game come on you know he
began being a drug from the pineal gland
of some exotic South African animal that
enables you to stand still without
making a movement but your your
functions of breathing cells for 24
hours and and Muskie was having a
problem with this drug I mean and people
ask me but 100 would give away as
credentials to some wild ass hippie
didn't ride them on the campaign tracism
as a prank says I mean you just couldn't
have asked for anything better and as I
say that year of the campaign coverage I
just I just had the best time
occasionally I go out and meet him on a
camping Trail the late nights were
hysterical but but the filing of the
copy when he'd write this stuff and you
just couldn't understand
where the hell did this idea come from
you know